hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
since we've now gone through the 10
principles of intuitive eating
a lot of you have been asking me how you
can instill some of these skills
into your family specifically how can
you get your picky kids to eat well
without forcing them into restrictive or
obsessive food behaviors like you may
have grown up with
so today i'm going to be sharing all of
the secrets to help raise a competent
intuitive eater now before we start my
quick disclaimer the information in this
video is for entertainment and
educational purposes only
so you should always speak to a
healthcare provider about your unique
healthcare needs
also the technique i am sharing here is
not meant to shame parents
who have a different approach if what
you're doing is working for you
amazing i just want to share the gold
standard for infant feeding and dealing
with picky eating
and of course a big reminder to
subscribe to this channel
and ring that little bell so you never
miss a video
okay folks real talk most of us were
probably raised in what we call the
clean
plate club and therefore we're taught
that we couldn't leave the table
or have dessert until we ate our
broccoli and peas
maybe our caregiver used the airplane to
sneak food into our mouth
or we were bribed with chocolate in
order to behave
or we were withheld a fun activity until
we choked down a food that we really
didn't like
all of these seemingly harmless tricks
may have encouraged us to ignore
our hunger cues and choke down our
natural
and normal fear of something new to
appease the adult at the table
or to get what we really want now if
you're a parent raise your hand
if you've ever said or tried one or more
of the following to get your kid to eat
if you have your broccoli then you can
have ice cream
just one more big boy bite and you'll be
done
i need you to at least try everything on
your plate
never letting your kid have any kind of
sugar fast food or other
junk food or hiding vegetables in sauces
smoothies or muffins without telling
them
all of these common feeding strategies
may seem like they work in the short run
because they get
healthy food into the bodies of our
children but they don't encourage
children to become competent intuitive
eaters as they grow up
in fact the concern is that these tricks
may actually encourage your kid to
distrust you
to distrust their own satiety signals to
distrust the forced upon
healthy foods and to obsess over certain
bad or forbidden foods basically it
causes the
opposite effect in the long run of what
we are really trying to accomplish
the reality is that hunger satiety and
body trust
are things that babies are innately
experts in
and it's usually not until they start
solids and the bribes and tricks
and little little hacks begin that they
forget how to listen to their body
so how do we give them this control back
while still
encouraging a picky eater to eat well it
starts with a division of responsibility
so what is the division of
responsibility developed by feeding
expert ellen satter
the division of responsibility is a
theory of feeding that acknowledges
children's
natural self-feeding and food regulation
capacities
and gives us as parents the
responsibility to create a supportive
environment
where our kids can thrive as competent
eaters
the division of responsibility suggests
that as parents
our job is to determine what foods are
served at meals or snacks
where that meal occurs and when that
meal occurs
our child is given the autonomy and
choice to determine
what they eat of the foods that is
served and
how much they eat or if they eat it all
now i know it might sound crazy
at first to give your toddler any sort
of freedom
when it comes to eating i mean how can
they possibly know what they need to
grow and thrive
well let me tell you in this situation
they do
and there's actual evidence to support
it the division responsibility is
also recommended as the gold standard of
feeding by a ton
of major pediatric societies and health
authorities so
this is no joke the goal of the division
responsibility is to raise a
competent eater which is a related term
to the more popular intuitive eater
now when given the freedom to eat in
response to their own hunger and
fullness cues
children are better able to eat the
amount of food that they need
and grow in a way that is right for them
in other words
they can maintain their body's settling
point because there is not that external
pressure
dictating their consumption when they're
not being pressured
they're more likely to be open to trying
new foods
and when foods are not dichotomized as
good food and bad food or
what you must eat in order to get what
you really want
they all occupy a level playing field
the result is that kids don't obsess
over sweets
or fear the healthy foods that are being
forced upon them
and that's a really good thing so now
let's break down the facts
on how you can get your picky toddler to
eat with some easy steps and tips
first model eating competence i don't
think it's reasonable to expect a child
to eat something
if their role model is not eating it as
well
and if we go even further back to when
children are starting solids
i also don't think it's reasonable to
expect a child can even
learn how to eat solids without a model
sitting with them doing the same for
older children
research also suggests that eating
together as a family is linked to better
academic performance
higher self-esteem and resilience and
lower risk of depression
substance abuse teen pregnancy eating
disorders and obesity
for these reasons i strongly suggest
always eating as a family at the dinner
table
start with just two minutes for those
really really little ones
and work your way up to 15 to 20 minutes
at the table what if your kid eats at 5
p.m and you and your husband prefer to
eat at seven
move the family schedule around to make
meals a priority
i cannot stress how important this one
step is so
if you get nothing else out of these
recommendations
make it be this if you absolutely can't
make schedules work between you
and your partner and the kids then i
suggest kind of switching things off
with your partner
or another caregiver to ensure that at
least one
person can eat with the children at
almost every meal
there will always be instances where you
you know you got to go to an event or
out for dinner and you have to let the
kids eat alone and in those situations i
suggest
at least having a snack with the child
so kind of like a mini meal of all the
same components of their meal
and then you can finish your meal out
with your partner or wherever you go
second eat family style
children like autonomy and serving a
meal family style is a great way to
reduce waste
and also give your kiddo the opportunity
to choose
what they want out of what you have
offered if you pre-plate your child's
food you risk
a overwhelming them with too much on
their plate which
often can result in them not eating at
all b
putting unsafe or fear foods on their
plate which
may upset them and freak them out of
eating anything at all
and c increase the likelihood of
waste under the recommendations of the
division of responsibility
it is imperative that we give our
children that control
third be respectful but don't cater
remember
you decide what you're going to make for
dinner and when it's going to be served
and where it's going to be served not
your toddler you do not need to
ever cater to a picky eater but the
suggestion
is to build a balanced meal that you
enjoy making and eating as a family
and to ensure that there is always one
safe food or
fall back food on the table so a safe
food is something that
assuming your child is hungry that they
will reliably
fill their belly with even if they're
not up for trying something new
or eating a food that they're just kind
of like learning to like
so serving a safe food helps our kids
trust
that they can help satisfy their own
hunger in a way that makes them feel
safe for a lot of kids let's be real
this is usually the carb food right so
bread rice pasta fruit maybe it's milk
but you know your kid best make sure
that there's a lot of this food to go
around
in case it's all your picky eater eats
fourth offer variety
satur would suggest always making sure
that there is some kind of carb
protein vegetable and fat i would agree
i mean
we want to offer a variety of the
different food groups
and let our kids choose from those
offerings as for the meals themselves
you can of course have your family
staples and favorites but i do recommend
switching things up
and offering a variety of different
carbs proteins
veggies and fruit so that your kid gets
exposure to a variety of foods
and you don't get stuck in a brutal food
rat
number five make food taste good
this is so important in this day and age
because it feels like a lot of mommy
bloggers and wellness influencers are
constantly pushing a no salt no sugar
no fat no fun lifestyle and extending it
onto
their kids poor kids right
do not be afraid to make your kids food
and your food
taste good and that often means adding
fat
some salt and some sugar these are just
tools in the chef's toolbox
so you do not need to feel guilty about
smart use of
any or all of them well of course i
allow my kid
fun foods that are packed with sugar and
salt and are easy to like regardless
i do try to focus my use on these
add-ins
to what i call more challenging foods so
for example
i want my kid to learn to like oatmeal
so i'm going to put a little bit of
maple syrup or honey on top
i want my kid to learn to like salmon so
i'm gonna add like a soy
brown sugar glaze i might want my kid to
like broccoli
so i'll serve it with a cheese sauce on
top
kids crackers and like sweet berries and
things like that are
easier for my kid to enjoy as is so
there's no need for me to
doctor them up with more sugar or a
fatty dip if i don't want to
use salt sugar and fat smartly and your
kids will be
much more likely to eat and enjoy these
naturally nourishing foods
number six stop pressuring remember the
division of responsibility rules
you did your part by choosing the foods
that would be served they now have to
decide
what they're going to eat and how much
of it they're going to eat
if they just eat their safe food and try
nothing else at that meal
you need to just kind of zip your mouth
for now and don't try to get in there to
make that meal
you know more healthy or more balanced
if something is on the table that they
don't yet
like or are learning to like you can
simply say
you don't have to eat it no pressure no
games
and over time they will let their
defense down and be more willing to try
something new
if the meal time experience is pleasant
and the more times they see it
the more likely they are to touch it the
more they touch it the more likely they
are to put it on their plate
the more they put onto their plate the
more likely they are to put it into
their mouth
and of course the more often they put in
their mouth the more likely they are to
eat it
and enjoy it this can be a long game i
get that it's frustrating as it can
typically take between
8 to 15 exposures of a food for a child
to accept it but
it is absolutely worth the wait
if we pressure we ruin our chances
potentially for life so keep the
learning experience
positive and pressure free number seven
do not react this is a really tricky one
but it's
really really important that we stop
making a big deal
of meal time when your kid does or
doesn't eat something that we want them
to eat
or not eat if we gasp and cheer the
moment that our kid puts
a carrot in their mouth they will start
to get suspicious that a carrot
is something unusual for them to like
they might not do it again
if we make a big fuss over them eating
too much of the cookies on the table
they might recognize that cookies are a
big deal
and they better eat as many as they
possibly can in case mom doesn't serve
them again
keep your cool if there's no pressure
we also have to ensure that there is no
praise if you
absolutely must say something when they
eat something that you're proud of which
i get
try something like i love this family
time or
ask them a neutral question about the
food like
what does the tofu taste like to you is
it crispy is it soft
just don't make a scene
number eight build a schedule and
reliable routine
and stick to it if you have a kid who
refuses lunch and then 20 minutes later
they're begging you for a snack
then they get to the dinner table and
push their food away
you likely need a more reliable meal and
snack schedule
if we want our kids to try something new
or eat something
other than their safe food they need to
get to that meal or snack
with an appetite i recommend ensuring
that there are at least a few hours
between each meal and snack
if your kid is whining right before a
meal because they're hungry
you can ask them if they're able to
maybe wait 15 or 20 minutes until
dinner's ready
if they can't then now is a good time to
sit them down for a little appetizer
something that is kind of part of the
meal but already ready so
cut up veggies and dip is always a
really easy option
and that brings me to number nine thou
shall not lie
or hide vegetables there are so many
books and blogs and suggestions on mommy
groups about how to trick your kids
into eating their vegetables by like
hiding them in sauces or muffins or
smoothies etc
i am not really a fan of this technique
well i am all for making food more
nutritious so of course
that means i add vegetables or nut
butters or whole grains to my recipes
whenever i possibly can
if a child is old enough to ask what is
in something
it is very important that you are
transparent and you tell them
children are incredibly smart when it
comes to picking out food that they
don't like
and by lying to them about the fact that
there's spinach in their smoothie
it communicates to them that spinach
is something that is so bad it needs to
be hidden
it needs to be lied about it also makes
our children distrust
us when it comes to food and the
division of responsibility is
all about fostering trust if a young
child
asks tell them what is in their food and
why
you can say that spinach gives it a
lovely green color or the yogurt makes
it nice and creamy and thick
you don't have to get into the fact that
it adds iron or vitamin c or whatever i
mean
communicate in language that your kids
will understand
but communicate honestly number 10
get them involved kids love control and
a lot of picky eating is about control
especially in those early toddler years
when kids are given some autonomy to
help out in some way
they're way more likely to want to try
so again
we don't want to become short order
cooks here but we could
theoretically give a child a choice
between two vegetables for dinner
do you want the broccoli or the carrots
which one sounds good to you tonight
we could also take them grocery shopping
and allow them to choose
one new fruit to try that week also
there's a lot of tasks that you can get
them involved in
when it comes to meal prep in the
kitchen so things like washing produce
adding ingredients stirring things
together etc
you are still creating the boundaries
here but you're giving them a little bit
of autonomy
to safely work within them number 11
say goodbye to dichotomous language and
get descriptive
we don't really have any food rules in
my house but
we don't use the word t-r-e-a-t
why why what is so bad about that well
just like words like junk food versus
healthy food
children are really quick to associate
foods like treat
and junk with things that they're not
supposed to have and that are
limited but highly valuable meanwhile
they see foods that are called
healthy as the ones that mom and dad
really really want them to eat
if my son asks for a treat i just don't
repeat the word back i simply call it
whatever it is so
it's cake it's a cookie it's ice cream
etc
yes of course foods are not all created
nutritionally equal but we can make them
morally equal
by neutralizing our language a lot of
parents also find themselves describing
a sweet food or junk food
as yucky to try to discourage their kid
from eating it
and yummy when they're trying to push
like a green bean on a kid
kids quickly figure out this little game
and again
they learn to distrust us so instead
describe
foods in neutral but descriptive
language
talk about broccoli looking like a tree
an asparagus
being snappy or a strawberry being nice
and juicy
talk about the cupcake as colorful and
ice cream and creamy and cold
and the cookie as chewy just don't call
it
good or bad number 12 do
sit down snacks so snacks have become
basically synonymous with treats or easy
foods in toddler speak
but really we need to start thinking of
snacks as
mini meals that offer as much balance
and nutrition
as a whole meal i recommend sitting down
as a snack
just like you would a meal and including
at least two or three different foods
but in a smaller serving so ideally
you're looking to get
two or more of what i call hunger
crushing foods so sources of fiber rich
carbs
healthy fats and protein this may also
be your time to offer a food that maybe
your child hasn't eaten a whole lot of
that day
so if your kid ate a lot of fruit at
breakfast maybe offer some crackers and
cheese for snack
if they had a lot of meat at lunch have
veggies or fruit at snack
whatever you choose just do it sitting
down number 13 is make bedtime snacks
filling not thrilling there will be days
when your kiddo just decides that they
do not want to eat anything at meal time
if this happens at breakfast or lunch
and then they ask for a snack
immediately after they get down from the
table you can remind them that you just
had a meal
but snack will be happening soon if this
happens at dinner time
i know a lot of us parents will be
worried about sending
our kid to bed with no food at all i
know i was
terrified the first time i did it
because this mama did not want a 2 am
wake up but in this case you can do a
bedtime snack
but as sadder says make it filling not
thrilling
so rather than an exciting fun food that
your kid might learn to kind of
hold out for every single night like
cookies or a popsicle
you can do a mini version of the meal
that they missed including of course a
lot of their safe food
or something really simple but not super
exciting
so milk or peanut butter on bread or
pita bread and guacamole
or yogurt parfait veggies and dip etc
filling not thrilling number 14
serve dessert with the meal
all right now let's talk about something
that you're probably really wondering
about and that's
sweets how do you get your child to stop
obsessing over dessert well there's two
ways to do this
the first is to put dessert on the same
playing field as the rest of the meal
and that means serving it with their
meal
but unlike the rest of the family style
meal which kids should
have access to on demand in whatever
amounts that they're hungry for
the dessert is a one portion only that's
the rule
they can eat it first they can eat it
last they can eat it sometime in the
middle of their meal
but once their dessert portion is gone
they have to move
on to other options on the table one is
that it doesn't teach our kids to eat
until they've kind of filled up on their
meal until they're full only to be
served dessert and then eat past
fullness in sweets
a competent intuitive eater would
ideally eat their meal until satiety and
be too full for dessert
and i've seen this happen with my son so
i do know that it is possible
the other is that we don't want them to
be putting dessert up on a pedestal
and that they must kind of drag
themselves through all the yucky food
before they get the gold this gives
dessert
far too much power now this approach
does not work for all children at all
stages in life
i found it worked great with my son up
until maybe 18 months
and then the toddler years brought on
the tantrums
some parents in this stage between like
two or three
find that they can't really explain to
their toddler why there's only
one portion so they eat dessert and then
they basically cry for the rest of the
meal time
let's be honest it is pretty hard for
anyone to feel hunger or fullness cues
when you're hysterically crying so if
you're struggling with
meal time tantrums maybe try picking
this technique up
later on when your child is old enough
to understand the one portion rule
and that they can have unlimited amounts
of everything else
number 15 offer unlimited sweets as a
snack
this is the alternative method for
dealing with sweets and the one that
i've been trying to use
now that i'm in the throes the terrible
twos so once a week or so
offer dessert at a snack in an unlimited
amount
this could mean like putting out a plate
of cookies or letting your kids eat as
much of their halloween candy as they
want
side note i did a whole other video on
halloween candy and sugar
right here but the key here is that this
unlimited sweet sesh
is far enough away from a meal that it
doesn't compete with
nutritious foods but it gives the child
the message that these foods are really
no big deal
and there's no need to hoard or obsess
over them when they're clearly
allowed to eat as much as they want a
child that is allowed
fun foods throughout the week will be
less likely to obsess over sweets
and eat a reasonable amount when they're
available this
is a really important skill that we hope
that our kids can carry on throughout
life
number 16 balance fun foods with
nutrition
if you're giving dessert or a snack that
is maybe less nutritious more often
you can balance out that fun food with
something more nourishing
so for example serving milk with cookies
or yogurt
with pie or cheese with crackers etc
this will encourage your child to put
the fun food and the nutritious food on
the same
level playing field and also will give
you the satisfaction of ensuring that
there is at least some nutrition going
in throughout the day
and finally trust your child to grow
into their healthiest happiest weight
now this is a big topic admittedly so
i'm just going to keep it
top level but it's very important to
trust this process as it pertains to
your child
and their weight don't be freaked out if
your child eats a lot less or a lot more
than other children in his cohort
children do not need to be put
on diets restricted or be force-fed
if you're not employing pressure and
bribes and tricks
a healthy child will eat the right
amount of food for their body
you need to just trust that often a very
small
child will make a parent nervous so
parents start interfering with eating
which
really only perpetuates their
disinterest in food
and often a very large child will make
parents very nervous so they restrict
and the child eats as much as they
possibly can when they get the chance
if you're not doing these things and
your child is still not eating or
growing well
then it's really important to speak to
your pediatrician about other possible
feeding issues
including oral motor development tongue
ties
behavioral concerns and developmental
delays okay so now i want to cover some
commonly asked questions about
dealing with picky eaters one what
happens if he only eats
the safe food if you've been pressuring
your kid to eat healthy foods or
restricting fun foods in the past
it's very likely that your kid is going
to only eat their safe food
or only eat dessert first it's natural
for a child to see the forbidden food
be served and try to get as much as they
possibly can
before you go back to your old
pressuring ways give it
time your child will need to learn how
to trust
that you're not going to cut them off
and you're not going to force them to
try something that they're not yet
comfortable with
remember keep your cool keep putting the
vegetables or whatever
food it is that they're learning to like
on the table
but not expecting or insisting that they
eat it
keep being neutral when they pick it up
put it on their plate or put it in their
mouth
keep trying to make the food taste good
with a little bit of salt or sugar or
fat
whatever and of course expose
expose expose now next question
what if i run out of the safe food so
ideally
we want to try to ensure that there's
enough of that safe food to go around
but of course our fridges and pantries
are not magically replenishing
so i often sometimes run out of fruit
because my family eats so much of it
so if a safe food is in limited quantity
you may want to offer two safe foods on
the table so
this for example could be maybe fruit
and cheese
what if he eats nothing at all do not
panic
it happens see my tips on offering a
filling
not thrilling bedtime snack and for
younger toddlers this might be the time
for their milk
keep in mind that hunger is actually
naturally suppressed by melatonin so
in my experience even the nights that my
kid eats nothing at all
he drinks his milk sleeps through the
night wakes up at a normal time
and just has a bigger breakfast you will
be surprised how amazingly resilient
they are
what if dessert is his safe food and he
just wants more of it
if you choose to serve dessert with the
meal keep in mind that this should not
be the safe food
since we really need to stick to that
one dessert serving rule so that way
it doesn't crowd out other nutritious
foods shouldn't we teach our kids that
sugar is
bad for them children are born with a
neutral attitude towards food
if we start saying things like sugar is
poison or candy is bad for you
kids will start thinking that all foods
that are bad
actually taste really good and they
develop a skewed relationship with food
keep language neutral and just call a
food what it is
it's not a treat it's not bad it's a
cookie it's a lollipop it's a cake
next how much should my child eat
so a lot of people will give you these
specifics about how many tablespoons of
food per month or year
of life a child should eat but how much
your child
needs is so highly variable between
children
and within children between days that i
find that these guidelines
just stress parents out more and force
them into restriction
or pressuring behaviors i prefer to
serve food family styles so that kids
can therefore choose
what they want to put on their plate and
you can limit the waste
if you're pre-portioning your child's
meal give them just
one or two pieces of each thing and let
them
ask or motion for more what if my child
is overweight or
underweight according to the division of
responsibility it doesn't matter what
the current size of your child is
the recommendations here are the same do
not pressure the child to eat or
restrict foods
and their weight will fall where it's
supposed to and yes
even overweight children should have
access to fun foods
and desserts without it being used as a
bribe
restriction and pressure often will do
the opposite
of what you intend and will only make a
small child eat less
and a large child eat more than what
their body
actually needs now what about the no
thank you bite or
one polite bite i get why parents use
this but
it's actually against the tenets of the
division of responsibility
it teaches children that they are not
allowed to trust their body
when it says no because they have to do
something for an adult
we want to teach our kids to be able to
trust their inner gauge
when it tells them that something isn't
right
and this extends far beyond food to
other important areas of life like
strangers for example so instead of the
one bite rule
you can teach your kids that you respect
them to listen
and trust their body you can teach them
if they do not want to eat something
to say no thank you i'm still learning
to like
beans for example if they don't like
anything that i've offered should i make
them a separate meal
if you have offered a safe food and they
still are not interested
in eating consider that they may
genuinely just
not be very hungry and you can try again
at snack time
you really don't want to cater to each
child by making separate meals when they
don't eat
or don't like what's being originally
served or they may just learn
that they can hold out on dinner to get
the mac and cheese or the pizza or the
chicken nuggets that they really like
stay strong and just trust that if you
did your part by offering the safe food
that you need to just let them do theirs
what if my kid sees a favorite food on
the table
while they're having lunch and starts
screaming that they just want the banana
so i put this question in there because
this is what my kid sometimes does
all the time so i figure i'm not alone
remember
you are the adult you decide what foods
are being served
and if you didn't choose the banana as
the safe food or
as an option at that particular meal you
don't have to give in
i don't you can simply say we can have
the banana for a snack
this afternoon or tomorrow but right now
we're having cherries
and you've still got lots of different
foods on the table to choose from
whatever it is that they're crying about
just make sure that you do put it into
the rotation often enough
that it doesn't become a novelty so for
example
my son knows that there are rainbow
sprinkles in the cupboard
and sometimes he will ask for sprinkles
on his food i know
he likes sprinkles so a few times a week
i will preemptively
kind of add them to his meal you want to
be preemptive about these things
that you don't get into the habit of
them having to throw a tantrum to get
foods that they like
then you give in and then they learn
that screaming at the table is how you
get what you really want
are there any non-pressure tips to get
my toddler to try or eat new foods
honestly there are a lot of fun ways to
encourage kids to try new foods
without having to resort to food rules
and pressure
some examples that i love are using new
fun utensils cutting food
into fun shapes with cookie cutters
serving food in a fun bento box or a
colorful container that they like
talking about the food on the table
without pressure like show me which food
is green
show me which food is blue and honestly
just keep putting the food on the table
and modeling good eating behavior i want
to remind you that none of this is meant
to shame a parent for how they feed
their child
if what you are doing is working for you
amazing
keep it up moms and dads but i want to
share this evidence-based approach with
you for raising a healthy
competent intuitive eater since so many
of you struggling with picky eating have
asked and this really is the gold
standard on how to approach
feeding if you want to print this out i
have a picky eaters
cheat sheet that you can download when
you subscribe to my blog so
i'm going to leave a link to that below
and on that note if you liked this video
be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below if you have any
questions as it pertains to
intuitive eating or child nutrition or
child feeding picky eating etc
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
you